d-wade when did you first meet him first
time I met I was my rookie season in the
NBA I've been a big I have three
favorite players was Michael Jordan
Allen Iverson and Kobe Bryant 10 games
and set my rookie season we played the
Lakers here on this court Shaq calm
along Gary Payton and Kobe Bryant
I told Kobe the story 2016 at the
all-star game when he allowed us myself
Chris Paul and Carmelo to host a
thank-you dinner for him and I told him
in that game in the fourth quarter I got
my opportunity to garden for the first
time and it was in transition and I was
scared as hell and I remember thinking
to myself you watched him play over and
over you know it's move
you know it's move and I just guess
right and I ripped them and I remember
thinking this don't matter if I don't
finish this basket and I came down I hit
the floater and I just thought to myself
can I believe what just happened I'm
calling all my boys back at the crib and
let them know that I just ripped Kobe
Bryant and that was my first opportunity
he don't remember that one because it
wasn't a big moment but for me it meant
the world it meant the world that I got
a chance to play I guess one of my idols
I got a chance to have a moment against
one of my idols and it just went from
there and the next year Shaq got traded
to Miami and right away Colby and myself
was pinned against each other and I'm
like no this is my one of my favorite
players but I understood the business
understood what we was out for was out
for championships and every time we
played each other I had to act like I
didn't did I didn't care that I was
playing against my one of my idols
elbows he falls don't help him up you
know all these things I had to get used
to and that was hard because I grew up
wanting to be like this
want to be like him
and what's enough for me that I've had
the opportunity over the years 2008 came
and I got a chance to play in the
Olympics and I remember the first day
that I really had a real conversation
with Kobe it was the day before the
first Olympic practice 6:30 in the
morning my trainer Tim Grover gets me up
and said hey we got to go get our work
in before we get there before you guys
get to practice and I go to the weight
room it has only one other person in the
weight room and it's Kobe Bryant and
Kobe's an opposite and I'm on opposite
and we're not really saying what's each
other we just get not working and
towards the end of the workout it was a
it was a drill that Tim made us do that
you had to get into push-up position and
hold yourself and see how long you can
hold yourself and he paid me and Kobe
right next to each other to see who can
hold each other the longest his
competitor drive my competitor drive it
was a long as I've ever held myself up
and after we got done doing three sets
that Kobe stood up and said you just
like me Tim I can tell me this was just
like me and from that moment on I've had
his respect
and for me as a young kid coming into
this league it was one person that I
wanted the respect from was one person I
wanted to look at me as his equal and
look at me eye to eye and it was Kobe
Bryant so getting this news the other
day I think I've been in shock for two
days and this is the first moment where
it actually feels real my buddy right
now is I'm shaking I'm numb but I just
want to talk to the to the people out
there the fans out there I went to the
gym this morning and I just wanted to be
around people and I saw people in the
gym that didn't even want to be there
but they they was at the gym
I saw people with Kobe gear on with Kobe
shoes on Laker gear on so people are
working out but they really was just
staring off in any in the days but I
just want to let them know that it's
okay to feel whichever way you're
feeling right now it's okay to be hurt
it's okay to cry it's okay destroy
motion it's okay to have laughter it's
okay to talk about to get around people
and talk about the moments that you
shared with Kobe Bryant it's okay to
find that community right now to get
around a group of individuals to just
talk about moments and talk about
memories because that's all we've been
doing in my house for the last two days
not only is it okay I'd encourage it and
Kenny when I called you the